the story you'll hear more than any
other story in your entire life is the
story you tell yourself
about yourself and a lot of people
watching this right now don't know that
they have the permission
and the power to write an amazing story
because when you do when you choose your
thoughts or your soundtracks
it turns into new actions which turns
into new results and a new life
getting on camera starting a youtube
channel or making a tough decision in
your business
requires both confidence and courage
fear and overthinking at best can
increase anxiety
and at worst it can leave us paralyzed
and stuck
in that moment when it comes to starting
your youtube channel
how do you get over the fear and create
confidence
on camera well in today's episode we're
diving in with our friend
john acuff my name is heather torres and
you are listening to the
think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow a high impact
and high profit youtube channel
and then take that impact and influence
and turn it into
revenue well today we are actually
diving into a
great interview that sean cannell did
with our friend john acuff
we're going to be learning about the
three r's to tap into the power of
overthinking
what are those and how to power up your
videos with both
comedy and humor and today's episode is
brought to you by
think master class we actually have a
special
live session happening on monday that
i'll tell you more about
later on during this episode well let's
jump into
today's featured content and i'll hit
you back up at the end of today's
interview
i am so fired up for today's podcast
because my friend john acuff is going to
be really helping us
build our camera confidence punch fear
in the face
and really overcome overthinking that
can
affect all of us whether you want to
start a youtube channel whether you want
to
get on camera for your next video
whether you want to make a big decision
in scaling your business it can be
really easy to get into
analysis paralysis and overthinking and
so
if you're just meeting john though john
is incredible new york times
best-selling author of
seven books including the brand new book
soundtracks which
just hit the wall street journal
bestsellers list he's an
inc magazine top 100 leadership speaker
he's spoken to
a lot of people hundreds of thousands
but like maybe a few brands you've heard
of
fedex nissan microsoft chick-fil-a nokia
comedy central just some of those highly
engaged social media following
and recently has not only launched some
new podcast stuff but has been
active on youtube and so i'm so fired up
for him to give us some tips
so we can be more courageous in starting
and growing our youtube channels as well
as just learning about how to turn
overthinking into a superpower
john acuff how's it going it's going
great man thanks for having me dude i'm
looking forward to it
i am so fired up to have you on uh the
podcast and i want to hear a little bit
about
your story and things in your journey
with overthinking but just off the
top like how much of a problem
is overthinking and do you think that
the pandemic 2020 especially has really
even added more to that problem yeah so
what's
interesting the researcher i work with
this guy named mike peasley he's a phd
just a genius
we asked 10 000 people if they struggle
with overthinking and
99.5 of people said yes and this was
before
2020 like 20 20 was catnip for
overthinking and i'll give you an
example i've been telling people
everything is a thing so the other day
somebody went to shake my hand
and right before i did i was like should
i refuse to shake their hand what if i
give him an elbow what if i fist bumped
him what do i shake it but then i put my
whole
arm into a vat of hand sanitizer as if
to say
excuse me while i wash off this deadly
pandemic you just tried to murder me
with sir and then i looked around the
room i was like is this a handshaking
event what does that say about us
politically
i thought all of that right before i
shook his hand you know what i thought
two years ago when i shook somebody's
hand
nothing everything is a thing and so
overthinking was already an epidemic
and now every little part of your life
has extra thinking baked into it and so
it's widespread
man that is so true and uh that it's
such weird vibes there's i the other day
it the mask wasn't fully covering the
nose i i felt
like i was the worst human being in the
world yeah you were trying to kill
grandparents
whose grandparents am i trying to kill
today yeah man
crazy culture crazy overthinking vibes
how about this though
what do you think about for people who
are getting on camera starting youtube
channels
trying to get in front of starting a new
podcast or something like that some of
those things you've been doing that
stuff for a while but you recently
really got serious about your youtube
channel
where does overthinking come into
creating content well overthinking comes
into where you go okay i want it to be
perfect
i want it to be amazing i don't you know
i want my first videos to be the best
videos i've ever had i want this to go
really really well and then it fires off
all these kind of perfectionism
thoughts of okay i i can't get into
youtube until
you know one one really easy example is
i'll meet people that'll go
i can't launch my channel i can't do it
until i have all the information until i
know
everything i'm going to do until i've
got the right logo until i have all
these pieces
and i'll tell them we haven't lived in
an all world
for 100 years you will never have all
the information
what you will have is enough so switch
out the word all for enough okay
here's enough information for me to
launch here's enough information for me
to get the right camera here's enough
information for me to
step in front of the camera but if you
say to yourself i can't make youtube
videos until i have
all the information you'll overthink it
and you'll never actually launch
man that's some powerful stuff and you
recently started your youtube channel
can you talk about that journey i mean
you maybe it's existed for a long time
but you started getting consistency
barely it barely existed i mean i had i
had like i planted my flag and then i
was like i'll see in 10 years
um and so for me part of what happened
is i do two things all year i write
books and then go speak about the books
at companies
and last march i'm a live event speaker
i'd say it's 70
of my my business um all of it got
paused
every event i had either got cancelled
moved to another year or put on pause
and so all of a sudden i stopped and
went wait a second i better figure out
and it's an overused word but i better
figure out how to pivot um you know i
essentially lost my job
what am i going to do and i've been
teaching people a question they can
answer
and ask in moments like this the
question is what would have made this
season
easier look at your life and go what
would have made it easier and then go
build that so when i looked at my life
and said
what would have made this season easier
a youtube channel was the most obvious
answer if i had an additional income
stream
if i had the chance to share ideas with
clients via video if i had more on
camera
experience i mean i'm doing tons of
virtual events right now but imagine
sean if i had spent five years
practicing being engaged and energetic
and connected
with a youtube channel i would have been
so much better off now i don't stand
there and regret that
there's no point going i should have
started a youtube channel 10 years ago
one of the biggest lies that'll keep you
out of youtube is it's too late
it's not too late that's garbage this is
the perfect
if you've got breath it's not too late
and so for me
i realized okay this would be easier if
i had this ability
if i had a youtube channel and that's
what made me say okay it's time to
invest in it it's time to get
you know serious about it it's time to
learn about it that's what kind of
kicked off my journey into youtube
wow and so grateful and definitely check
out john acuff on youtube because he's
got incredible content a good channel to
subscribe to um it's hard to fix
something
we don't know is broken um and your new
book is called soundtracks
and i love the analogy you can break
that down for us
because one of the things you talk about
is broken soundtracks this place where
we're
overthinking and the patterns the music
in our mind what is a soundtrack and
what's a sure-fi fire way to recognize a
broken soundtrack
so a soundtrack is just my phrase for a
repetitive thought i've heard people say
a thought is like a leaf on a river or a
car on the highway cloud in the sky
for me it's a soundtrack because a
soundtrack plays automatically usually
and has the ability to completely shape
the moment for instance
we're talking about video like if you
see a video and it opens up on a
beautiful idealic scene in a small town
and there's a white picket fence and
kids frolicking in the street
and then they play an ominous song
suddenly it changes everything suddenly
you're like there's a clown in the sewer
like i know there is like but if they
play a vanessa carlton thousand miles
you're like oh she's making her way
downtown like this is a rom-com like
matthew magana he's gonna be part of it
the soundtrack's changed everything
they've done studies on if you hear the
jaws soundtrack
how what that does to you physically and
so that's what a soundtrack is and most
people
don't know that they get to change their
soundtracks
most people think a thought is something
they have not something they hone
and so they let thoughts show up of
their own and they don't understand that
no
you get to choose what you listen to and
and we talk about storytelling a lot you
and i because that's a lot of youtubers
storytelling
the most important story the story
you'll hear more than any other story in
your entire life is the story you tell
yourself about yourself
and a lot of people watching this right
now don't know that they have the
permission and the power
to write an amazing story because when
you do when you choose your thoughts or
your soundtracks
it turns into new actions which turns
into new results and a new life
so the clearest way i'll give everyone a
really easy way to figure out
do i have some broken soundtracks write
down a desire
write down something you want to do
we're talking about youtube i want to
start a youtube channel
i want to grow my youtube channel i want
to scale my business i want to hire
somebody
i want to do less editing because i got
so big whatever it is
write down to desire and then listen for
the first thoughts to come
because here's what i say every reaction
is an education
what's your reaction to that little bit
of dreaming even just that tiny bit of
dreaming
what's the reaction and if your reaction
is negative you might have a broken
soundtrack
that's some powerful stuff and um in the
book is soundtracks of course we'll link
that up in the show notes
and we coming up are going to talk about
the three r's on how to tap into the
power of overthinking
um but one of the things that i love
is i love zig ziglar one of my favorite
quotes that he said is you don't have to
be great to start but you have to start
to be great and you were friends with
zig ziglar and interviewed his son
tom for this book what are some of the
things that you learned from zig ziglar
over the years
well so i got to have lunch with zig and
his wife a few years before he passed
and he was just incredibly generous i
said to him
i'm trying to do what you do i'm trying
to encourage people
you know on a large scale i'm trying to
bring hope to people i'm trying to teach
people
and he really walked me through a bunch
of ideas but when i got
so i bumped into tom zigler his son for
this book because
i didn't want to write about positive
thinking i'm a fairly skeptical person
like i'm i'm a sarcastic person
i grew up with serenity now on seinfeld
and saturn live like i'm good enough i'm
smart enough and doggone it people like
me
but i kept running into really talented
really high achieving people
and if i talk to them off camera off mic
and i'd go hey
what do you think about positive
thinking they would kind of get quiet
and go well i give myself a little pep
talk you know in the afternoon or i've
got some declarations or i've got some
mantras i got some affirmations and i
was like oh no i'm going to have to
research positive thinking
and so i went to the source which is zig
ziglar he's kind of you know a godfather
of motivational thought in this country
and that's where i ended up interviewing
tom zigler i think the interview with
tom ziegler is worth the whole price of
the of the book
um but i essentially played stump the
ziggler i kept trying to find like well
what about this
what about this like what if this
happens like are you saying that you
should just
you know lie to yourself and say like
you know you know
um like everything's fine like
everything's fine fake it till you make
it he's like no we never teach fake it
to
make it he was like no and what i
learned is you never fix a broken
soundtrack with a new lie
and so an example of that is he like tom
said
you would never say i'm in the best
shape of my life if you're not
because your brain knows you're not and
it triggers off cognitive dissonance
your brain goes these two things aren't
true
so we're not going to work together he
said instead you tell the truth in
advance
i'm getting fitter and fitter every day
in every way so i'm getting better and
better at youtube every day in every way
and so i kept trying to find holes in
his plan and
i mean i think one of my favorite
stories he told me about his dad was he
said you know
if you fly more than once you're gonna
get delayed you're gonna have a flight
canceled you're gonna get delayed
and his dad in a moment like that that
was negative
was always ready because he had his most
important work with him he always had it
with him
so a a delayed flight wasn't an
emergency a delayed flight was an
invitation to do his most important work
so you can just see zig ziglar he's at
an airport and they go your flight's
gonna be two hours late he's like
cool i'll be right over there just
crushing he always prepared for negative
moments like that and so for me
the conversation was really fascinating
it turned into us
studying affirmations and taking 10 000
people through an affirmation study to
go
okay what works about affirmations
what's the science behind it and it's
it's fascinating even just listening
like they did a 12-year study a guy
named dr haskins at the university of
tennessee
12-year study played five minutes of
negativity on a radio
for people and just five minutes a day
lowered their belief in the universe
it it decreased their willingness to
help other people
it increased their depression five
minutes a day how many of your viewers
your listeners
only watch twitter for five minutes a
day only watch
facebook for five minutes a day only
watch the news so the negative things
we're feeding ourselves
have a tremendous impact now the good
news is so do the positive things
and that's where it comes down to going
i'm gonna create the kind of soundtracks
that push me forward
versus pull me back and when i do that's
when new stuff happens
man that's such a powerful concept and i
i it's interesting that you bring up the
news
it feels like there's always been the
chance that you know
drama kind of sells the scariest stuff
sells the
you know the the most negativity is what
gets us to click through
the headline or gets us to stick it you
know coming up
the worst news you've ever heard the
dangerous poison you're probably
drinking right now in your kitchen and
you're like
hey am i guzzling poison this is
terrible
and so i love this concept because i can
our our listeners are already thinking
about man i want to have the soundtracks
so i get the right
you know results of my life build
momentum with my youtube channel but i
know it's always kind of like
there's different people i'm that way
where i'm like i don't like to listen to
a lot of news or some people say i don't
listen to the news at all and then some
people critique that and it's like now
you need to stay informed though
what is your thought to that the tension
of that conversation because people go
to extremes
especially like sometimes people of
faith are like i never watch the news
and that can even signal
like kind of an ignorance angle uh but
on the flip side you're backing it by
science what do you think the wisdom is
to navigate that
well i mean here's a really interesting
study that i put in the book
so scientists at nyu brought in college
students two group
two groups of college students they said
hey we want you to make
sentences out of these words so they
gave them a bunch of words a word bank
said make some sentences the other group
same same instructions but inside that
word bank
were words related to being old they had
secretly hidden words like retired and
bald in florida
so they make these sentences the two
groups and they say hey right down the
hall
is the second part of the test will you
please walk there and so while they were
walking there the scientists secretly
timed them to see how long it would take
and the people who had been exposed to
words related to being elderly
physically walk slower just reading
words about being old made them
physically
change the way their bodies work so the
power of negative words on who you are
and how you feel
is a billion percent documented it's
powerful
and so what i'd say to that is i think
there's a middle ground between
you're ignoring everything and you're
informed like when i you know during the
pandemic when they would show the
running death toll like a
like a slot machine what was that doing
for my life
what was that like what information did
i need from that like how did that
change my day
other than just give me buckets of anger
buckets of fear
buckets of cortisol like that wasn't
providing any help
so when somebody says you need to be
informed i'd go well what did you do
with the information
like how did that how did that improve
your life how did you help the person
that that information was about
so i think there's a real temptation go
like no i'm just being informed
but i think there's a there's a a part
of your life where you go
this isn't adding anything and i'm not
adding anything to it
i'm just stuck in this loop this
negative loop okay
you know what does it look like for me
to be informed but also recognize
these things have a cost like these like
these things have an
impact on me um is it is it an impact
i'm happy about or is it an impact
that's actually discouraging me
is it an impact that's making me feel
like i don't want to help is it an
impact that's making me hate my neighbor
instead of
have conversations with my neighbor the
problem with news the problem with
social media is it flattens individuals
into ideas
it's easy to hate an idea it's hard to
hate an individual it's easy to hate
somebody who's flat
it's hard to go well that's mark my
neighbor like we vote differently but
as my guy like we talk at the grill and
we work our issues up you can't do that
as easily when it's on twitter
and i think that's where people get
confused wow
wise um kind of pivoting into
one of my favorite things about your
style about your writing
is the book is really funny and uh which
is probably why
jim gaffigan endorsed the book right and
um
a couple questions about humor is it's
one of the most like i've heard you know
a spoonful of sugar helps the medicine
go down
right and uh you're funny in keynotes
you also really put a lot of work into
your obviously into your writing
into your speeches uh and keynotes and
your talks
one of the most powerful aspects of
powering up youtube videos or making
them more interesting
is is not just like even if you're
educating is edutainment bringing in
some humor
bringing in some wit um i i kind of want
to unpack this with you
like if you have any tips
like i love this question so the problem
is
youtubers will often read okay you
should be funny and then they'll
try to be funny in a way that's not
their version of funny
and it comes off like they're wearing
their dad's coat at the eighth grade
dance so they open up the video
and they they read something that said
you always should have a joke and then
go
what about this joke and it's not
connected to the content at all it's not
authentic at all and they do then do a
hard left turn to like and now time for
content
and you're like whoa there was no
transition so what i say to youtubers is
if you're dry in your sense of humor at
a dinner party be dry on youtube
if you're slapped stick at a dinner
party be slapstick
on youtube what people want is authentic
humor so once you realize
that like it's about self-awareness so i
tell youtubers all the time
be self-aware so that when you say
something that's funny in real life to a
friend
don't then become a different person
when you get behind the camera
people want to see who you are not who
you're pretending to be to perform for
the camera
so the other day i mean the way i do
that a really practical sense because i
always try to bring things to the
practical
i carry a notebook i have a notebook
with me and if i say something that i
think is funny or it's an observation
i'll write it down and i'll workshop it
later and so like i'll give you two
examples one
i was walking into my ups store and i
saw a bumper sticker that said my dog is
smarter than your honor student we've
all seen that bumper sticker and for
this time i thought no it's not like no
like dogs eat vomit like i've never seen
like i've never had somebody go
oh our ap calculus students are amazing
but unfortunately they eat a lot of
throw up they just do or like
dogs get afraid of thunder i've never
heard somebody go our ap students are
great but we
have to put thunder shirts on them if
the band plays too loud because they're
scared of loud noises like
and then i was like well the joke there
is where did you go to school how bad
was your high school
that you legitimately think your dog is
smarter than an honor student like
that's not true at all and so
i observe that i save it and then i can
work on it here's the key like the key
to creativity in my opinion i put this
in the book
dorothy parker who's an amazing she was
an amazing writer she said
the definition of creativity is a wild
mind and a disciplined eye
the wildness is you fill your head with
all these different topics
somebody else's video angle something
that sean said something your neighbor
said
a song lyric from john mayer whatever
you have this wild wild
mind and then you have the discipline to
see the connection you have a
disciplined eye
to see okay when i link these three
things together i create something fresh
and something new so for me
like when it comes to creating youtube
videos i don't believe in writer's block
i believe in idea bankruptcy
like i don't believe in writer's block i
believe in idea bankruptcy i never sit
down to work on a youtube video without
bringing some friends
i never sit down to a blank page so that
was one of the ideas that
the sticker with the um honor student
the other one was just the other day
i was talking to some friends about
jacuzzis and i just said jacuzzis are
weird because like if friends came over
for dinner you would never be like you
guys want to take a bath after dinner
like but that's what you're saying like
that's essentially what you're saying
when another couple comes over and gets
in the jacuzzi like you would never go
you guys want to come over for dinner
and then after maybe i don't know we'll
just all get in the bath
you guys want to do that like so
jacuzzis are weird will that turn into a
joke someday
maybe maybe not but i've collected it
and it's in kind of the
rock tumbler of my creative process and
then will i have the discipline to see
the connection between other things
that's part of my creative process
[Music]
hey heather here and we're going to jump
back into this interview in just
a quick second but i wanted to let you
know that today's episode
is brought to you by
thethinkmasterclass.com
we are doing a special live training
sean cannell
here at think media online for you on
monday
may 24th at 5 p.m pacific
standard time we're gonna be diving into
the
one youtube strategy that sean used to
generate
57 346 views
per day and how that video makes over a
hundred thousand dollars per year
just from those views without adsense
you're gonna learn the three reasons
youtubers fail and how to avoid these
mistakes
the one strategy that's getting views
and making money on youtube
and the most recent tactics based on all
the new updates that have happened
in 2021 with youtube you can register
today for this
free master class at
thinkmasterclass.com this special event
is happening on
monday may 24th at 5 00 pm
pacific standard time you don't want to
miss it so
go to thinkmasterclass.com to register
for this free training
today all right let's jump back into
today's interview
with john acuff
[Music]
man that's so powerful and i want to
kind of go a little bit deeper on
just your craft because i mean as a
communicator
you're also with respect and those
listening i mean you're
seven books into creating content
blog posts you you've you've sharpened
the saw over the years and over your
career
um when it comes to really youtube's
communication i mean no doubt about it
like at the end of the day
and you're communicating potentially if
you're also so many listening are doing
the editing they're adding the music
they might add sound effects
you also have the chance to not just
deliver on camera but to potentially
think about
timing intros footage and it could be
like an accordion it could be very
simple and you need to just perform and
be
funny or educational or whatever or
you're using all kinds of different
mediums
what are ways just specifically for your
craft
you you've turned pro a long time ago
you you
you approach this not as a hobbyist but
as someone who does this very seriously
how have you sharpened the saw of your
craft as a communicator
there's a couple ways one is repetition
so
you know you want to get better at
youtube make more videos like that's i
mean like
that's the shortest that's a haiku
probably like but
somebody asked me the other day they
said hey i've got to give a 10 minute
speech
once a week at my company and i'm not
very good at it and i said well how
often do you practice it
full and he was like i don't i just like
go over my notes and get up and do it i
was like well you're giving yourself one
practice
50 times a year so if you practice three
times it's 10 minutes we're talking 30
minutes
if you practice three times every time
you would give yourselves four years of
experience in one year
like you would like everyone in the
world would get better if they did four
years of repetitions in one year so
that's
i mean that's the first thing the second
thing is i try to create in layers
i recognize that my craft has layers so
the first layer is just the idea
like the words aren't right you know if
i was you know if we were talking
youtube specifically
the transitions wouldn't be right i'd be
storyboarding i'd just be like what's
the
what's the idea i'm trying to
communicate and then for me i'd go okay
how do i how do i make it positive i
tend to my first drafts are
pretty mopey like they're very like
counting crows 12-minute version around
here at the sydney opera house like
they're kind of like
like a little bit mopey i'm like all
right well i want them to be more
positive so i add a positive layer and
then i'm like
i want them to be specific i have a note
on my wall that says oh here it is
i have that this is for every youtuber
out there specific is sexy
the more specific you make what you do
the better when i
instead of saying to you sean
researchers have done some cool stuff
i go hey nyu professors hey dr haskins
at the university of tennessee like
that lens sexiness where you go oh okay
that's like
that's that's better and then i add a
humor layer so i think a bit like a
layer where i go back through and go
today i just posted about the hitting
the wall street journalist and i wrote
the post and i was like it's kind of
it's not super positive and i was like
and i want it to be funny so i just told
the story that this whole week
and i wanted to be authentic my wife has
been saying hey don't get disappointed
don't get disappointed if you don't hit
a list don't get this one like she's
been prepping me
and i said she said that to me all week
the only thing she said more was can we
make out
because being married to a writer is
intoxicating so like now i've added a
humor layer so i'm still communicating
but i've layered on so i think a good
story has
layers and then the other thing is i
think every youtuber needs to know
the best stories are the ones i tell
myself everyone watching your video
has more vocabulary personal to them
than you could ever tap into i have 45
years of
memories and language so if you'll start
the story like i think
amateur youtube is overstuffed like
there's so many ideas
because you're afraid to let something
breathe and great youtube there's enough
space that i can finish the story you
start it so like you start a story about
the beach
and you have no idea knowing that when
you do that if you leave me space i'll
remember ipswich massachusetts i'm in
the third grade my dad's in seminary
we're sitting on the roof of my house
which my mom was not happy about and we
can see miles away this
thin little strip of north shore this
little blue ocean and it was the best
and so
if you'll leave me room i'll tell that
story which is why every porsche ad if
you look at a poor shad
a poor shad could have a thousand words
on it it doesn't
it has a really good headline it has a
money shot of the car and it has two
little paragraphs because a porsche
isn't a car a porsche is a story
and they know the person that's going to
get into that car
buy that car has a story about porsche
that if you'll leave them room they'll
tell the story themselves that's how i
kind of think about my craft
wow um super powerful and
i want to kind of steer into our
thoughts
and you know for listeners still this
has been so encouraging
but there's the the giant ahead of us
that is staring us down still and it is
that
that we haven't actually got on camera
and pressed record yet
uh or we haven't maybe shared that bold
idea and we've been playing it safe with
the content that we've been creating
um so many different business owners and
people building their online business
it's that risk of hiring or that risk of
i mean you start thinking about
overthinking
are they going to be crazy am i going to
waste my money are they going to hate me
am i a good leader
uh am i going to is this going to be is
this the end of us
it's the ship sinking i mean i like you
uh we're we're going through some
expansion at think media right now major
expansion like actually like eight rolls
which is like over 50 of the size of our
team so i'm like are we going to make
payroll
are we going to destroy our company
culture are we you know
a lot of different things you have three
questions people should
ask their thoughts when i'm going
through these overthinking thoughts what
are those questions
so you ask your loudest thoughts i
always say that because nobody has time
to ask every thought like who has that
much time you have a million thoughts
so you take your loud ones imagine your
loud boombox like you take the loud ones
and you ask it three simple questions
is it true is the thought i'm thinking
right now true
second question is it helpful does it
move me forward
or does it hold me back and third is it
kind
if i set it to a friend would they still
want to be my friend and the reason you
ask three is that
let's say your question is or let's say
your ideas
i won't be a good leader of people i'm
trying to explain my company i'm just
going to use you as an example sean
i'm hiring eight people i'm not i'm not
ready to lead them
that might be true dude like you might
like you might not be perfectly ready in
the same way you weren't ready for a
baby
like no one's ready for nobody goes i
got parenting figured out like my
daughter goes to the prom next weekend
i'm not
ready for her to go to the prom but so
that first question
you might say is it true but then you go
is it helpful just saying that to myself
over and over
make me do more videos or less and we'd
all go it actually it makes me do less
and then you say is it kind
if i set it to a friend where they want
to be my friend you go no i talked to a
podcaster the other day
and he said he's been number one in his
category for nine
months and the the soundtrack he's been
listening to is you're just lucky you're
just lucky you're just lucky
and he said if my friend told me hey
i've worked really hard and i built this
thing and it's been successful for nine
months i'd never go
you're just lucky like only a jerk would
say that so why would you say that to
yourself
and so that you know if you can't answer
yes to all those questions it might be a
broken soundtrack
and it might be something that you need
to retire wow
and start playing a different soundtrack
uh that'll lead us to the results that
we want to
get what's an example of that for you
where you uh
have some soundtracks where you had to
see if they checked the box on those
three questions
okay um here's one so i had to write
down
ask for more i wrote that on august 27
2020
because i was undervaluing what i was
worth
in negotiations and conversations about
projects or money
i was undervaluing what i do and i
needed a reminder that
not only is it okay to ask for more you
should ask for more
and so for me that was one where you
know instead of going okay
who are you to ask for that amount of
money like all these broken soundtracks
around money i said okay i need to
create a new one
i need it to be simple so i remember it
i need to put it up and so
we talked about a little about that
we've highlighted the three r's the
three r's are you retire your broken
soundtracks
you replace them with new ones and then
you repeat them so often
they become as automatic as the old ones
and so for me
this was the replace i took who are you
to ask for that amount of money i said
no i'm gonna start leaning into this
ask for more ask for more ask for more
and then i'm gonna i'm gonna
repeat it so often i actually start to
believe and actually start to lean into
it
and i'm gonna have other ones here's
another one i feel like i'm grabbing
notes right off the wall but this one
says
people are trying to give you money
people are trying to give you money
and i needed this one because sean i had
broken soundtracks from
bad business situations i've had
business situations where
i got taken advantage of money got
stolen i p all this
and it's really easy for me to listen to
a broken soundtrack that says
everyone is going to take advantage of
you unless you're really careful
you got to completely be on guard you
got to watch out for where people are
trying to screw you
and when i listen to that soundtrack i
roll into meetings and i'm defensive
and i'm tight-fisted and i'm judgmental
and i
and i don't really show up in the
meeting the way i want to show up so for
me i need to be reminded when i'm having
a zoom meeting
from this very spot that's right people
are trying
people are trying to give you money oh
that's right let's do this like ask for
more like
you should ask for more and we've taught
you and i you know have been friends for
a couple years
i've talked to you about that process
like that's a work in process
that's the last thing i'd say you have
to repeat it you have to repeat it one
of the greatest mistakes you can make
especially in youtube
i meet so many youtubers that go i tried
youtube didn't work for me it didn't
work and i'll go what does that mean
like i didn't monetize
fast i didn't whatever they wanted and i
always go it's the same with diets
people go this exercise didn't work and
i go well how long did
did you work on it they'll go 10 days
and i'll go how long did it take you to
gain the weight now go 10 years
you gave yourself 10 years to gain the
weight in 10 years to lose it so the
soundtrack that i give everyone there is
don't give the problem a year in the
solution a week don't give the problem a
year in the solution a week
you can't quit youtube that quickly
because it takes time to get going
it takes time to have results it take
like here's the other thing if no one's
watching your channel right now
congratulations you just got the gift of
invisibility
you're getting to make your mistakes and
be invisible
and make mistakes that you don't want a
hundred thousand people to see
like you don't want a million people to
see like you've got the gift of
invisibility and you're going to work on
stuff you've got this private little lab
and you want it to grow and you're going
to grow it
but it's going to take some time and
you've got to be kind to yourself
for that that thing to take some time to
repeat so if you say
i feel inadequate in front of the camera
and you felt that way for five years
don't think you'll change that in five
days like you get you take this really
new fresh little soundtrack and put it
up against this
five-year monster that's been doing like
weights in the prison yard and you go i
wonder why these two things had a
problem
you've got to repeat it you've got to
give it time you've got to be patient
with it
and that's not always easy but it is the
path
man i'm so excited about all the value
been adding and i know
our community is just buzzing and i'm
also just excited about
the book soundtracks and really actually
this term i mean immediately
it's so sticky for me personally friends
even our team
is sharing i really believe this is
going to become part of the vernacular
because music is such a part of our
personal lives and a part of culture
and we can think about it it's just a
great illustration for
um you know positive music negative
music the music that we love
needing to get a new road trip playlist
needing to get a new playlist uh
for building that youtube channel
building that business um
i want to talk a little bit about the
book in just a second but i am curious
what what are some of the the
soundtracks what are some of the albums
what are some of the artists
that have uh just been a huge impact in
your life and all of a sudden nostalgia
or emotion comes up
uh with some of those classic jams oh if
i hear don henley boys of summer like
instantly i'm like out on the road today
i saw a deadhead sticker on a cadillac
like that's one of the best lines ever
written in my opinion because it
instantly tells you
a generation has grown up the deadhead
sticker shouldn't be on the cadillac
people are changing a little voice
inside my head said don't look back you
can never look back like
that song oh if i hear that song um
counting crows i joked about the county
crows but they are probably the band
i've seen the most
um they're on my college mount rushmore
like i remember mr jones sitting in the
car trying to rewind the tape and my
date wouldn't listen i was like
i was a lyric guy so like no no no like
like when i play a song
i want you to hear the lyric and if you
start talking over the lyric i just have
to replay that section and it's awkward
for both of us
so that's part of it and then for
writing books like like moby has an
album called like hotel
ambient um where it's just i can't write
to lyrics so like
sigross like i don't un speak icelandic
or whatever made up language they add to
their icelandic as if icelandic wasn't
difficult enough already
so like albums like that i can write to
and then like if i'm running then i need
something that's aggressive and
lyric-based and like
i need eminem on eight mile like that's
what i need that's when i need that so
yeah i
i love music i just think it's such a
powerful thing my first concert i'm
curious yours my first concert was
uh disclaimer my big sister
uh of course who has influence on your
life sure got me
really into new kids on the block and
otb and kotb i get it that's right and
that was my
tacoma dome washington and i even had
the new kids on the block stage and the
new
kids on the block barbies like they were
they were the barbie yeah that's
yeah yeah yeah who do you think was the
best new kids on the block who
like were you like oh i'm a i'm a danny
wood guy nobody's a danny
isn't donny one of them donny is yeah
he's still out there jordan knight i
mean it's hard uh
his brother jonathan which was like the
like like the
i don't know like the tbs edited for tv
version of jordan knight
yeah i know a lot about in kotb
apparently that's so funny
was what was your first concert how amy
grant michael w smith
okay hardcore just win smitty if you
will
that's what everybody nashville calls
them yeah i think it was like just a
night of synthesizers
um but yeah that was uh that was my
first and then my craziest concert was
rage against machine like
it was the only concert where i was like
i think i'm gonna get punched in the
head a lot at this concert like
there's a lot of people punching like i
didn't realize what what a punchy crowd
this was it was a good show but it's
a lot of punching a lot of people's on
parade exactly
exactly i mean yeah so funny soundtracks
soundtracks so
tell us about the book um again you can
check out show notes
if you're listening on audio on youtube
of course uh
leave your aha moment an action item
today
in the comments and you can always hit
the like button um but
uh man i'm excited about this book i'm
halfway through it i'm loving it
and i love because again as an aside
there's a lot of books that i like and
get a lot get a lot of good information
out of them and i'm like that's exactly
what i wanted i needed but i have to
work for it
there's not that many good well written
books personal opinion there's they're
not
good books but they're great content and
they will help your life there's
something else when it actually is also
a good book meaning the stories flow it
pulls you through it it's organized well
it's a nice read and almost like a
spoonful of sugar helps the medicine go
down
you get the medicine as well but it's
it's done in a pleasurable way just
that's my feeling
because you're a great writer obviously
a skill sh set that you've sharpened
and i think the humor aspect as well as
getting science-backed
data that's really gonna help us rewire
our soundtracks so i'm a huge fan of the
book and i recommend everyone pick it up
but come on what's your vision for the
book cause
i think this is not only something
you're proud of but something that
you're gonna be
shouting over the soundtracks for a
while
yeah i think it's gonna book it's a book
i'm gonna sit on it feels like a book to
steward
um that's a word i keep coming back to
like i'm gonna do my best to steward
this idea
um i think that it feels different to me
in that
it is sticky it is you know my i i feel
like my job as a communicator is to put
handles on ideas i'm a handle maker
i try to put handles on ideas because we
have enough ideas the world is full of
ideas we don't have handles on them
where we can pick them up with us and
take them into thursday or take them
into next month
and so what i like to do is take really
complicated ideas like thinking or
overthinking and go okay how do i
simplify this how do i give somebody
three questions
that they can actually ask and here's
the thing like when you do something
like that you create what i call trojan
horse truth
where it looks simple like the question
is it true is simple like
none of those words nobody listening to
this or watching this was like what i've
never heard the word helpful before
that's crazy what a brand new idea but
when you ask it and
you actually sit with it you find things
that you're going to be surprised you
found i mean for me
we saw somebody say okay their old
soundtrack because we created this
graphic where people could go here's my
old here's my new
and this guy said my old soundtrack was
i can't be a good dad because i didn't
have a good dad
and he said my new soundtrack is i can i
can learn how to be a great dad
and so like that dude's kids will be
different
because he's no longer telling himself i
lost the ability to be a good dad to my
own kids because
my dad was in a great dad to me like
that's life changing so like
i think the book is just getting started
like i really do
i really feel like um and then from a
company perspective
like even the ability to go no here's
how like here's the problem with
your company soundtracks every company
has soundtracks you start to realize
like
every couple has soundtracks every
family has soundtracks every company has
soundtracks
and that's where you go wait a second so
like an easy soundtrack at a company is
like a new one i would give
them is um curiosity beats criticism
curiosity beats criticism
you have to actively say we're doing new
stuff so we're going to be curious
because if we shoot it down before it
has a chance to grow and the fascinating
thing about that is
the people at a company who are the best
at the old way fight the new way the
hardest
because they have the most to lose and
that throws leaders for a loop because
they think
this is my top guys my top girl like
they're gonna be so fast to do the new
way
they're not and you go wait a second is
it an attitude it's not they just
have so much more to lose and so you
have to foster a community in a culture
where you can say
okay we choose curiosity like google did
a study called project aristotle they
spent
millions of dollars studied more than
180 teams 35 different statistical
models to figure out what do the best
teams at google have in common
like what are they doing and the number
one thing above all the data show this
is what the data showed
the best teams at google have what's
called psychological safety
which is the ability to ask questions
and make mistakes and suggest ideas
without being judged unkindly and that's
the key
so when i say is it kind i'm trying to
get you
in your team of one to be kind the
reason you haven't made youtube videos
is
before you've even written down the idea
you've judged and gone that's a dumb
idea
it's already been done i'm not as like
i'm not as good as mr beast
like that's the crazy thing youtubers do
is they they find the like most popular
person
with a team of 50 and a budget of 2
million they go
my video just wasn't as good of course
not if you drove past a building
with 50 people in it you wouldn't go i'm
just trying to compete with that
building it's going to be challenging
because they got three stories
and i'm just hearing this civic but i'm
gonna that's my competition no it's not
no it's not that's so unkind and so
that's what's really fun to me is to go
well how do you apply soundtracks to
parenting like how do you apply it to
your business to your youtube
because it'll change everything you do
like i really genuinely believe that so
yeah i feel like i'm going to be on this
one for a long time
man i love it soundtracks the surprising
solution to
over thinking john so grateful for the
value you've added today
you're working on some projects uh
people can of course uh
get the book and there's uh details for
that and show notes but
if people want to connect with you
social media and uh
what can we expect i'm excited about
your youtube channel i'm so grateful for
posting youtube content yeah
so i'm author john ace on youtube i've
got a podcast called all it takes is a
goal
and i i recently interviewed a woman
named colleen berry that nobody's heard
of but
a few years ago i met her and because i
asked people
have you ever used your mindset to
change your circumstances and she lost
her job as a documentary filmmaker
ironically enough she had to take three
other jobs one of them was as a
receptionist and she decided i'm going
to change things
and now she's the ceo of that company
like she went from being the
receptionist
to the ceo and it was this amazing
interview so that's what i would say go
check out that episode it's on my
podcast all it takes is a goal
i think it'll be really encouraging and
then i'm just at john acoff on twitter
and instagram and acheup.me and all the
locations you can find me all over the
place
john a cuff thank you so much thanks
sean
[Music]
well i hope you enjoyed that interview
and this special bonus session
that we brought to you here on the think
media podcast thank you so much for
listening and make sure that you
register
at thinkmasterclass.com for that special
live youtube training that sean cannell
will be doing it's happening on monday
may 24th at 5 00 pm that replay will be
up for
only a short limited period of time so
you're going to want to make sure that
if youtube is your next step
and you're ready to stop overthinking it
to get unstuck to break through the
fears and really get
confident when it comes to growing your
youtube channel
and you want to make sure that you're at
this special event happening on monday
may 24th at 5 00 pm and make sure you
like and subscribe to this podcast if
you're listening or watching
on youtube and if you're listening on
anywhere that you get your podcast from
we would love for you to rate and review
the podcast
if apple is where you are listening in
so
make sure you leave your review on what
you love about the think media podcast
and maybe we'll read it on a future
tuesday featured episode
thank you so much for watching and we
will catch you or listening let me say
that
watching or listening to the think media
podcast and we will catch you
in the next episode bye